in the last video we were able to find
the equation for the regression line the
equation for the regression line for
these four data points what I want to do
in this video is figure out the
r-squared for these data points figure
out how good this line fits the data or
even better figure out the percentage
which is really the same thing figure
out the percentage of the variation of
these data points especially the
variation in Y that is due to or that
can be explained by a variation in X so
to do that I'm actually gonna get a
spreadsheet out I actually have tried to
do this with a calculator and it's much
harder so hopefully this doesn't confuse
you too much to use a spreadsheet and
I'm going to make a couple of columns
here and spreadsheets actually have
functions that'll do all of this
automatically but I really want to do it
so that you could do it by hand if you
had to I'm going to make a couple of
columns here this is going to move my X
column this is going to be my Y column
this is going to be the column I'll call
this y star this will be the Y value
that our line predicts based on our x
value this is going to be the this is
going to be the error error between
error with line error with the line so
it's going to be the difference let me
call it the squared error with line
actually me just do the error with line
error with other the squared error
squared error squared I want I don't
want this to take up too much space
squared squared error with line and then
the next one I want to do the squared
squared error actually no idea already
had the squared error and then the next
one the next one I am going to have I'm
going to have the the squared variation
squared variation for that Y value for
this y value squared squared from from
the mean from the mean Y from the mean
one I think these columns Bites by
themselves will be enough for us to do
everything so let's first put all the
data points in so we had negative two
comma negative three that was one data
point negative one comma negative one
then we had one comma two then we have
four comma three
now what will what does our line predict
what does our line predict well our line
says look you give me an x value I'm
going to tell you what Y value I'll
predict so when X is equal to negative 2
the y value on the line is going to be
the slope so this is going to be equal
to 41 divided by 42 x times our x value
and I just select that cell and just
just a little bit of a primer on
spreadsheets I'm selecting the cell d2
the cell d2 I was able to just move my
cursor over and select that that tells
me the x value minus 5 over 21 minus 5
divided by minus 5 divided by 21 minus 5
divided by 21 just like that just like
that so just to be clear of what we're
even doing this y star here I got
negative two point one nine that tells
us that this point right over here this
point right over here is negative this
point right here is negative two point
one nine right over here so when we
figure out the error we're going to
figure out the distance between negative
two and negative two point one between
sorry between negative three that's our
Y value if we're between negative three
and negative two point one nine so let's
do that so this so the error the error
is just going to be equal to our Y value
that's cell e2 cell e2 minus our the
value that our line would predict and we
want this so that just that value is the
actual error but we want to square it so
we want to square it just like that so
we will square it and then let me try to
do the right thing yep and then the next
thing we want to do is the square
distance so this is equal to the squared
distance of our Y value from the Y's
mean so what's the mean of the Y's mean
of the Y's is 1/4 so minus 0.25 is the
same thing as 1/4 and we also want to
square we also want to square that now
this is what's fun about spreadsheets I
can apply those formulas to every row
now and notice what it did when I did
that now all of a sudden
this is the y-value that my line would
predict it's now using this x-value and
sticking it over here it's now figuring
out the squared distance from the line
using using the what the line would
predict and using the y-value this one
and then it does the same thing and then
it does the same thing over here it
figures out the squared distance of this
y value from the mean from the mean so
what is the total squared error with the
line so let me just sum this up the
total squared error with the line is two
point seven three and then the total the
total variation from the mean squared
vary eight the squared distances from
the mean of the Y are twenty two point
seven five so let me be very clear what
this is let me be very clear what this
is so let me write these numbers down so
R squared I'll write it up here so we
can keep looking at this actual graph
I'll write it over here so our squared
error versus our line our total squared
error we just computed to be two point
seven four I rounded a little bit and
what that is is you take each of these
data points vertical distance to the
line so this distance squared plus this
distance squared plus this distance
squared plus this distance squared
that's all we just calculated on excel
and that total distance is two that
total squared variation to the line is
two point seven four or total squared
error with the line and then the other
number we figured out was the total
distance from the mean so the mean here
is y is equal to one-fourth so that's
going to be right over here so Y is
equal to one fourth is going to be right
over this is one half so right over here
so this is our mean Y let me draw a
little bit neater than that this is our
mean Y value this is our mean Y value or
the central tendency for our Y values
and so what we calculated next was the
total error the squared error from the
means of our Y values that's what we
calculated over here this is what we
calculated over here in the spreadsheet
you see it in the formula it is this
number E
to minus 0.25 which is the mean of our
Y's squared that's exactly what we
calculated we calculated for each of the
Y values and then we sum them all up is
22.75 it is equal to it is equal to 22
22.75 so if you wanted to know so this
is essentially the error the error that
the line does not explain this is the
total error this is the total variation
in the numbers so if you wanted to know
the percentage of the total variation
that is not explained by the line we'd
take you could take this number divided
by this number so two point seven four
two point two seven four over over
twenty-two point two seven five this
tells us the total this tells us the
total or the the percentage this tells
us the percentage of total variation
total variation not not explained by the
line or by the variation in X by
variation variation in X and so what is
this number going to be what is this
number I could just use Excel for this
so if I'm just going to divide so I'm
just going to divide this number divided
by divided by this number right over
there
I get point one two so this is equal to
0.12
so this is equal right over here this is
equal to point zero point one two or
another way to think about it is 12% of
the total variation is not explained by
the variation in X the total squared
distance between each of the points or
they're kind of spread their variation
is not explained by the variation X so
if you want the amount that is explained
by the variance in X you just subtract
that from one so let me write it right
over here so we have so our R squared
which is the percent of the total
variation that is explained by X is
going to be one minus that point one two
that we just calculated one minus that
point zero point one two that we just
calculated which is going to be
0.88 so R squared here is 0.88 it's a
it's very very close to one the highest
number it can be is one so what this
tells us or a way to interpret it this
is eighty-eight percent eighty eight
percent of the total variation total
variation of these Y values is explained
is explained by the line or by the
variation in X by variation in X and you
can see that it looks like a pretty good
fit each of these aren't too far they're
definitely much closer to this line
they're definitely much closer to those
though each of these points are
definitely much closer to the line than
they are to the mean line to the mean
line in fact all of them are closer to
our actual line then to the mean